yolande squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur serveur web on avait fait
une vidéo sur la démo de l'e3 du jeu il
ya environ deux mois et aujourd'hui on
va faire une deuxième vidéo dessus et
qu'est ce qui se passe là on est chez le
dentiste un dentiste un peu ghetto
airlines fait l'anesthésique dans la
gencive hop c'est le réveil accédants
sagesse ça n'avait pas de mine
vous n'avez pas bonne mine vous devez
prendre le soin de vous mais attend déjà
je veux une crème nivea tous les soirs
donc tu vas te détendre donc là je vais
terminer cinquième chapitre donc on est
au sixième chapitre et un total de
quinze chapitres et on va lire le
journal voilà pour pour se tenir au
courant de l'actualité de la ville
within le plancher de l'église
s'effondre aucun blessé des témoins
parlent de miracle
des fauteuils oui un mur casser une
maison une statue à l âge paris qu' on
va d'un coup se retrouver dans la photo
il ya le trou dans le sol en boîte ou l
infirmière je vais retrouver mon
infirmière aussi la femme fière
puisqu'elle fait là comme ça à bahreïn
les trois kilos je pensais que la
lumière à la pâte sa tête elle est comme
ça comme si elle avait muté meinau où
êtes-vous infirmière à bonbons faut se
détendre sous des formes à dafunk watts
et michael copon fort sur la tête
ok donc là on vient de changer de décor
d'un coup c'est ça qui est là ah ça
c'est un personnage de l'histoire qui
s'appelle leslie il entre à milan il est
pas bien là il pète un câble à a
peut-être distance en spiderman mais un
sixième sens comme ça oui c'est moi
sebastian oui c'est moi sébastien wyss
on attendait la ville avait un visage
miroir finalement c'est la beauté
éternelle ça et voilà on vient de
changer de décor fait la queue devoir
nous appelle on admire le beau paysage
elle sera début de vidéo calme là mais
c'est bien ça va être bien que chez nous
comme savoir que sur les photos
effectivement bon alors là dedans ça va
être le gros bordel je suppose soit on
se bat côté puis on se bat contre des
monstres
à moins que les pigeons soit en fait des
monstres es tu coures coup aux eaux qui
fait des pétards ou des causses appelé
des claques dois je sais plus quoi jeter
par terre et qu'ils aient etupes et 8
euros oddo voit cette porte je faire des
claques dos avec toi mon ami bonjour je
suis hyper beau gros noms ici bas à
temps mais faut pas le faire sur soi
même les claques de aussi un lui c'est
un pote à nous j'étais seul quand je me
suis réveillé une demi seconde plus tard
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] ça va on s'attaquera
désormais partout et moi ce que j'aime
bien faire dans un premier temps s'étire
et là bas pour que ça pète
oui mais ça arrive en masse doit
protéger pendant qu'ils vous la plante
le monsieur mais écrase salle auprès de
granby remet d'un couteau de cuisine
proche et du thé quad au hockey vous
faites pas y aménage par terre elle est
où elle est là et on doit finir dans sa
tête ça va pas tuer eux
hop là il veut at the beaches oui oui
bah merci oui c'est pas il m'attend pas
je pouvais crevé par terre en train de
ramper qu'il s'en foutait le monsieur je
te croyais amis encore mais [ __ ] y'a
plein de portes piéger et fouette eux
que je brûle brûle petit gros hop là un
problème de mâchoire en plein problème
de de banos fils autour de la tête fait
fâcheux parce que tu as fait mais ouais
super j'ai dépensé 800 balles et je
récupère 2 oh là là mais où l'a pas
atteint c'est toi je vais tuer après aaa
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle faire de la
merde ah bah merci oui allez on s'en va
en plus lui il a une méga grosse hache
dans les mains mais il en fait rien quoi
oh [ __ ] aux crocs au revoir à on
parlait soudainement et d'un coup il ya
une invasion de zombies et c'est la
panique s'arrête deux secondes oui enfin
pas long feu je confirme alors y'a quoi
dans ce coffre au sniper fusil de
précision de vie ailleurs peu commune
suffisait à beyrouth mais d'une lettre
date pas d'hier mais semble avoir été
bien entretenu et alors on va où on va
s'amuser
j'entends des bruits de monstres mais
comme si on avait absolument partout
quoi par exemple juste là j'ai pu tuer
par derrière mon infiltration et weening
boulette ou alors je vois des leviers
pour ouvrir des portes
est ce la bonne stratégie je suis pas y
toucher donc non passer par ocak san ou
ce témoin une là il ou le piège au et
bien là non mais il a jugé qu'ils
devaient emballer dans les mains pendant
mon pardon ça hors de la scène bien plus
des tentes d'un camp regardez regardez
oh non non non non lui il nous a pas
encore de lui nous a pas encore vu
furtivité schlick est lui par contre
pour la furtivité au sas 4 compliqué
quoique et il attendait sur le côté mais
il fallait pas beau garçon tout dans la
furtivité au boeuf
il est des milles au matin et voulait
nous piéger
moi je réserve ce sens là ce qui va nous
piéger
doudou oh merde [ __ ] lui tire pas des
petits trucs le mec c'est pas des [ __ ]
est ce qui t a cédé plus qui font moins
med quoi il faut qu'on les détruise tout
pour pouvoir rentrer et je dois les
détruire avec mon fusil de précision
ramasser plus tôt peut tirer ou voilà à
peut-être tiré là haut
que fais-tu un numéro à non non mais
attends ce ces jeux est en flammes
inutile de te débattre avec ton couteau
je te broie les rotules alors ça c'est
quoi à sa fermeté désactiver la machine
qui tira à voile à s'activer les deux
leviers qu'on ne fait pas activé je vais
en compte qu'on a plein plein plein
plein de munitions partout parce qu'on a
me détends tg en fait j'aime il me
détende pour rocher le jeune âge jusqu'à
ce point là et là du coup je te pu
retirer le mode détente regarder et
toutoune ou l'âge des munitions quoi on
va juste poussé une grille hop il ya des
messieurs qui tomberont au bon moment
huawei pourquoi est ce qui se passe ça y
est un chantier enfin wayne panneaux qui
dit chantier port du casque obligatoire
bordel et ben voilà on peut les utiliser
hop au mondial sont horribles elle me
pose carrément bois on laisse faire
que demander de plus je ne voyais plus
bordel chicas deux caisses il a si mal
de dents quoi bientôt ailleurs une fille
en bikini qui fera qu effectivement le
mode détente c'est de la détente
maintenant faut aller où tout droit à je
sais je sais beau et on l'a bien défoncé
tourner sa manivelle penser que ça
faisait de la musique danse attirer des
purs fdp
il ya du monde qui arrive je sais pas
par où mehamha par le ciel c'est nickel
mais il me met bientôt je vais quitter
cet homme il fait faire moi mais
regardez quoi pas et fait partie des
forces spéciales des états unis coréen
en place et ça je pense que c'est parce
qu'on est en mode détente
on a vu quand tu es en mode expert de la
mort il est assis en tailleur comme ça
contre le bury fait rien au delà du
monde la du monde en plein boucherie
c'est une belle scène c'est comme ça
qu'on fait dans les abattoirs de la
ville within le steak haché les bien
tendres après un allez on y retourne
ou allegro et sur son père résistant ce
qu'il ya du gras finalement c'est une
protection c'est la grenade coincé sur
sa route ils ont après avec le recul je
sais plus quoi penser de cet homme
finalement voilà pas fait rater et voilà
c'est la chute la tour infernale de
disneyland mais enfin l infernale
jusqu'au bout
et maintenant maintenant on devrait
pouvoir atteindre la tour sans problème
les attend ils entendent l'otan ce que j
ans micro oh oh oh c'est un piège c'est
un guet-apens aux non [ __ ]
hélas hélas hélas faut le bruit n'est la
boum boum boum ou alors le peut-être
mais juste un coup aux ménages
ça fait pas du bien
ah ça c'est les médecins les médecins
quant à malraux de ses conseils du
smecta et ça aussi donc c'est au choix
je t'attends démons vomi l'aveuglé bam
bam c'est une blague donc aux plats et
de deux
mais c'est bien c'est toi cette étoile
isolé dans la foulée t'inquiète pas
hopla a ses bons et la dernière qui
veulent tuer abbas et à la côte et non
il décède
oh oui on s'est fait du bien ça fait du
bien saloperies à tenter d'emblée lay
line ou trop le cas même en sommeil on
lui a dit qu'il était fort ça y est nous
est plus alors qu'est ce qui se passe
d'accord ça marche bien sûr surtout des
ratages est en panne alors voilà ce que
what you're gonna do là mon avis ça va
se passer au sniper ben alors on est une
petite toque et si tu arrives sur les
médecins conseillent aussi en cas de
toux de deux points de concensus dans le
torse mais comme tu veux un
c'est beau tu sais que ça bâton adacore
qui est guillotiné des gens comme ça il
y en a que deux ce sera facile non c'est
pas aux le piège
gg bombe ou beach au nom a du coup il
est inconscient il se fait kidnapper la
totale je veux pas les visées de la wii
où personne ne m'aidera mot joseph nulle
part monsieur du coup moins par contre
lui comme pour passer maintenant joseph
à d'accord ok je passe avec le moyen le
plus sûr du monde c'est ça une planche
de bois où tu dois mettre au point
je te couvre joseph boum c'est l'heure
de partir dans un grand boum
[Musique]
on a bien vu littéralement se séparent
là oui j'arrive
c'est là que nos chemins se séparent et
mon coup je me suis un fils là et vous
l'agencé dia fin de cette vidéo se
révèle with him on a échappé à ses
créatures démoniaques et puis j'espère
ne plus jamais les revoir même si je
pense qu'on va sûrement aller vous
croisez 3ème plus loin j'espère que ça
vous a plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude ou alors
a fait un footing avec saint joseph vous
serez en sécurité plus qu'en sécurité
elles-mêmes
normalement il ya eu zéro spoil dans
cette vidéo donc si vous voulez vous
faire le jeu vous pouvez le faire en
toute liberté ça sort surtout déjà fait
venir tous les noms sur tout sauf wii
wii et nintendo 3ds moi ça oh vous
cherchez sur google [ __ ] pis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et